today's class what we're going to do
first we're going to look at a position
from the sixth game of the World Chess
Championship match that is going on
right now in Russia then I'm going to
set up a position what we call a tabia
position from an opening okay from a
grand opening that grandmasters really
like to play and I want you guys to play
the position against one another and
then I'm going to go around watching the
games and I'm going to give you some
insights and suggestions hopefully some
really good moves so the first thing I
want to show you is the game this was
game 6 of the World Championship okay
and the mat just hide two and a half
points two and a half points from the
five games previous to this one Magnus
had won one game this she had won one
game and three games had been drawn now
this was the position that occurred in
the game and it was Magnus Carlsen to
play he's white I don't like the fact
that white has double ponds I thought
for example these pawns are a little bit
weak but I really like the fact that
these rooks are really active they can
and that this bishop and this rook
combine to make a good threat and to try
to capture and win that pawn so overall
my feeling was that I like Magnus
position
I preferred White's position and I
thought that Magnus might play move for
example like f3 why would this move f3
be a good move what do you think why is
that exactly the move f3 would actually
serve two purposes
the first is you're absolutely right
with the pawn here that rook gets
protected but if we go back for a moment
this Bishop on c6 attacks this pawn on
g2 ok the pawn on g2 is defended for the
moment but I like to move like f3 and
this isn't the only move or the best
move but I like this move because it
protects the pawn from attack it
neutralizes the bishop and it protects
the pawn the rook on g4 Magnus did not
play that move in fact he made a
catastrophe
he made a terrible move putting the
entire game in jeopardy with one move he
played the move king c1 to d2 and why
think about this for a moment in your
mind why was that move vichy has a
really good move what do you think why
is it terrible g8 rook to da okay so
that's a very reasonable move you bring
your rook into active play with a check
but nothing terrible happens in the
worst case white could just go back with
his king and nothing catastrophic has
happened so I like this move I like this
move very much but black amazingly
enough has any even better move Charlie
do you see why this was
still thinking very good alright notice
there's a problem right
notice that this rook which is
undefended these rooks are not
threatening one another
but if this Knight were to move the
rooks would be under attack yes show me
show me
Knight takes e5 wait a minute
can black really do that okay let's see
what's going on after Knight takes e5
notice that the rooks are now at the
rook is in a fork the knight is
attacking the rook this rook is
attacking this rook but check this out
did you see that this rook is attacking
this Knight did you see that so but if
white takes this night we lose the rook
black would take the rook and at the end
of this trade black has done very well
he's given up a knight but one in
exchange and a pond so that would be
very very good for black so rook takes
e5 is a terrible move white should play
rook takes g8 now he's a wreck up what
do you think this one I found Anand game
6 of the world championship match
they're playing for a million dollars in
prizes whoo so the outcome of the game
is very important now you played the
move Knight takes e5 which is the
correct move when magnus carlsen played
the move king d2 at
you guys ever felt this yourselves you
make the move and then you realize the
move you made was a mistake charlie
exactly and magnus recognized the same
thing he had this terrible sinking
feeling like oh my gosh I made a
terrible terrible move because now in
this position
White has just captured a rook correct
now if black captures the rook that
would be terrible because the knight
would be captured and at the end of all
of these trades well it would be a white
would win exactly
white would win but in this exact moment
and this exact moment Black has what we
call a wishin Zook do you guys know what
the word swishing xub means Charlie what
does it mean and in between move so the
idea is I capture you you capture me
okay but between in between my capturing
you and you capturing me you make us
wish ensue in this case I capture your
rook but you don't capture my rook right
away instead you make an in-between move
and that in-between move is what's the
in-between work what what rip - eight
seven no I will take your knight young
man what's the in-between with yes you
yes correct
Knight takes e4 he doesn't take the rook
instead he plays Knight takes e4 and
this is with a check whoa
so the night that was in capture gets
out of capture with a check to White's
King now white comes up to d3 attacking
the knight now what does black play
young man what dislike Bravo again black
does not recapture the rook but plays
Knight B to with a check to White's King
White's King has to move and now black
recaptures the rook so now what has
happened what has happened yes has lost
two pawns right so Magnus saw this
position and his heart nearly stopped he
was fearful oh my gosh he's blundered
the game away that could cost him his
World Championship title that is to say
when he meant after he made this move
King d2 he saw this variation and was
like yes in it I'm gonna get getting to
that oh you guys want to I'm trying to
set up the mystery do you guys want the
answer before the mystery is now this
she what this she was thinking was he
wanted to get counter play on the Queen
side so very quickly in less than a
minute of time thinking he just advanced
his pawn and after he advanced his pawn
he realized that he missed a chance to
win the game with Knight takes e5 and
now he felt terrible
Magnus realized ah I have a reprieve I I
get a chance to take my move back now he
moved his king away to e2 so that this
whole idea of Knight takes and Knight
takes is not with a check and the moment
of crisis had passed and Magnus went on
to win the game so the entire million
dollars hinged on a purchased a
particular position so after this game
Magnus now leads the match three and a
half two and a half points the match is
12 games so it's the first player to
score six and a half points wins the
match and the world championship title
this is actually something very strange
it's actually very common in chess that
you both have a blind spot that is to
say
imagine if you want if you will that you
and I are playing a game and I start an
attack on the kingside right and you're
getting worried and you're making some
defensive moves over there on the
kingside and we're both concentrating on
what's going on over there well both of
us might miss a move on the Queen side
that could change the outcome of the
game because we're so concentrated on
one side of the ward and it's a very
common thing that happens in chess now
what I want you to do is set up the
position from the starting position set
up the position and I'm going to create
what is called a tabia okay we know that
from the starting position we can do all
kinds of moves
all kinds of opening moves but I know
when I was starting playing chess I had
a real difficulty in the opening I
messed up all the time okay I messed up
all the time in the opening so I want
you guys to play games against each
other from a position that Grand
Master's play okay so that you get a
kind of a you'll get to a chance to play
like a Grand Master our first starting
position is going to come from an
opening called the Sicilian dragon you
like the Sicilian you like the Sicilian
how many of you played the dragon have
you played the Dragons oh wow so you'll
probably be the best in the class if
you're familiar with the Sicilian dragon
okay so on the boards in front of you
the opening move e to e for white
advances the pawn in front of his king
two squares the pawn in front of his
King White does it you got the black
side yeah okay okay
II for black responds with the Sicilian
defense c7 c5 okay as everybody got c7
c5 this is called the Sicilian defense
white develops his knight is Kings
Knight from g1 to f3 so Knight to f3
okay
so far so good everybody if you have any
trouble you raise your hands I'll help
you out black plays the move d7 d6
opening up the diagonal of his bishop
okay these are top Grandmaster moves
these are some of the most popular moves
in chess openings amongst the best in
the world
white plays D to d4 notice there's a
tension with these pawns now black
captures the pawn c5 takes d4
in this position has become known as the
open Sicilian white recaptures the pawn
on d4 with his knight okay so this is
what is called the open Sicilian black
plays Knight f6 attacking this pawn on
e4 white plays Knight c3 defending the
pawn on e4 and now we stop and think for
a moment from the perspective of black
he's kind of happy this bishop is doing
good things he's happy about his knight
at the moment his King is still in the
center and he hopes to solve that but
his real problem is this dark square
bishop and he wants to activate it yes
young man correct
g7 g6 this signifies what we call the
dragon the dragon Sicilian how does the
name the dragon get its name well if you
look at the pawn structure for a moment
these five pawns ok takes a little
imagination I know but this might look
to you a little bit like a dragon mmm
that's how it gets its name so black
plays g6 white develops his Bishop
Bishop to e3 black develops his Bishop
on the long diagonal the fianchetto we
call that the fianchetto how many of you
know that know that fianchetto what the
fianchetto a lot of people very good
very good
Bishop e3 Bishop g7 now in this position
White has a lot of choices White's a
little bit afraid that this night might
come to the g4 square attacking his
bishop disrupting his development so
White's most popular choice is to play
f3 stopping the knight from going to g4
black there's something very important
in the opening he moves his King to
safety by castling okay that's a safe
castle white plays Queen to d2
developing his queen everything so good
so far very good black develops his
knight Knight to c6 white develops his
Bishop Bishop to c4 black develops his
Bishop Bishop to d7 and white does
something very clever he castles and
brings his King into what he hopes will
be safety
now that Kings are on opposite sides of
the board it means that black wants to
attack White's King over here and white
wants to attack blacks King over there
okay we're gonna play the moves rook c8
Bishop Knight to e5 so these are all the
most popular moves in the opening of the
Sicilian dragon h4 so this is where
we're gonna stop and I want you guys to
find a partner somebody that you can
play against that's equally good I don't
want lopsided matches okay and play this
position I'm gonna come around and look
at your games and make suggestions